I think there are many leaders who I
think the house committee on science and
technology right now which is obviously
made up both Democrats and Republicans
is is starting to advance some very very
important legislation I think the kinds
of things that emerged from the rising
about the Gathering Storm report that
was produced a little while back and
that's now being used as the foundation
for policy by by the committee is really
good I think that Hillary Clinton's
speech a few weeks ago recently is a
textbook brilliant in terms of a view of
where science can go in the world I
think that there are some very simple
things that we're starting to see I
think I think even Newt Gingrich has
started to speak very eloquently about
the importance of science in America in
the future of America so it most
definitely most definitely is both a
democrat or republican issue i think
that i think that what we're starting to
see is the recognition that science is
not a you know an issue to sort of block
off and isolate as a you know an issue
that has its own lobbyists and that has
its own kind of causes and you know logo
it is a root issue it is it's not even
an issue it's it's progress or not
progress because you can most certainly
look at science and see its consequence
on national security you can look in
science and see its consequence on
environmental policy you can look at
science and see its impact on education
and obviously math and science education
science and jobs and economic
competitiveness science and the
perception of the United States in the
world it was missions like going to the
moon on that gave the world
a profoundly positive view of America of
what America stands for and it's
interesting to note that in the last few
years there have been more space
launches from non from outside the
United States than from within the
United States and it's in fact many
other nations now that are advancing in
very interestingly American like ways
space programs that although today are
not pushing technological boundaries
necessarily but they are pushing
geopolitical buttons and sort of
national pride buttons and the space
program in various parts of the world
right now is a sign of a progress and
and can-do attitudes that are
quintessentially American and we're
dealing with a NASA which although
technologically robust and
scientifically important is
aspirationally bankrupt
you